Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Breaking news happens anywhere, anytime. Police have warned the protesters repeatedly. Get back. CBC News brings the story to you as it happens. Hundreds of wildfires are burning. Be the first to know what's going on and what that means for you and for Canadians. This situation has changed very quickly.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、系列节目的抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。突发新闻随时随地都在发生。警方已多次警告抗议者。后退。CBC 新闻将为您现场报道事件经过。数百起野火正在肆虐。第一时间了解最新动态及其对您和加拿大人意味着什么。局势变化极快。
Helping make sense of the world when it matters most. Stay in the know. CBC News. Walk with us. Stay in the know. of our cultures. Dance with us. Join in. Feel the beat of the drum and celebrate. Come. Walk with us.
在最需要的时候，帮助理解这个世界。掌握最新资讯。CBC 新闻。与我们同行。保持关注我们的文化。与我们共舞。加入进来。感受鼓点，尽情庆祝。来吧。与我们同行。
Indigenous Tourism Alberta. In the move towards electric vehicles, Hyundai isn't just in the race. We're setting the pace. As Canada's most awarded fully electric vehicle lineup, our vehicles offer up to 550 kilometres of all-electric range and winter-optimized technology for all-season performance. Visit a dealer today to learn more about federal and provincial purchase incentives on eligible models,
阿尔伯塔省原住民旅游局。在向电动汽车过渡的进程中，现代汽车不仅在参与竞争，更在引领行业节奏。作为加拿大获奖最多的纯电动汽车系列，我们的车辆提供高达 550 公里全电续航里程以及针对冬季优化的技术，实现全天候卓越性能。立即访问经销商，了解合资格车型的联邦和省级购车优惠政策，
or go to HyundaiEVLeader.ca to learn how war keeps you going. Queen Fredegund was very depressed, for she had been stripped of much of her power by her great rival, Queen Brunhilde, and yet she considered herself a much better woman than Brunhilde. In secret then, she sent a cleric of her household, who was to gain Brunhilde's confidence by trickery and then assassinate her. If only he could, on some pretense or other, be accepted as one of her retainers and so gain her confidence, she could then be dispatched when no one was about. The cleric went off to Brunhilde, and by the lies which he told made his way into her good graces.
或访问 HyundaiEVLeader.ca，了解战争如何让你坚持下去。弗蕾代贡德（Fredegund）女王感到非常沮丧，因为她的大部分权力被她的死对头布伦希尔德（Brunhild）女王剥夺了，然而她认为自己比布伦希尔德优秀得多。于是，她暗中派遣了一名家臣，企图通过诡计骗取布伦希尔德的信任，然后将其刺杀。只要他能以某种借口被接纳为她的侍从之一并赢得她的信任，就可以在周围无人的时候将其除掉。这名神职人员找到了布伦希尔德，并通过谎言赢得了她的好感。
I am a fugitive from Greenfredegund, he said, and I seek your protection. He began by behaving in a most humble manner to everyone, and so gave himself out as the obedient and trusty servant of the Queen. But not long afterwards, they realized on what a treacherous errand he had been sent. He was bound and flogged until he confessed his secret plan. Then he was permitted to return to the Queen who had sent him. When he told Fredegund what had happened and confessed that he had failed in his mission, she punished him by having his hands and feet cut off.
他说：“我是格林弗蕾代贡德（Greenfredegund）的逃犯，我寻求您的庇护。”他最初对每个人都表现得极其谦卑，因此把自己塑造成女王顺从且忠诚的仆人。但没过多久，他们就发现他被派去执行一项多么叛逆的任务。他被捆绑并鞭打，直到招供出他的秘密计划。随后，他被允许返回派遣他的女王身边。当他把发生的一切告诉弗蕾代贡德并承认自己任务失败时，她惩罚他被砍断了手脚。
So that was Gregory of Tours in his History of the Franks, which is a great chronicle, often an eyewitness account in fact, of what happened in Merovingian Gaul in the late 6th century. So Gregory of Ator, Tom, I studied him at university. He was a great Gallo-Roman writer, descended from the kind of senatorial classes. It's a wonderful book. I know you're a big fan of the first line of that book, the greatest first line in all history. Yeah, I think it's my favourite ever written. Do you want to tell everyone what it is? It's so accurate. A great many things keep happening. Some of them good, some of them bad.
以上就是都尔的格雷戈里（Gregory of Tours）在他的《法兰克人史》（History of the Franks）中所记载的内容。这是一部伟大的编年史，其中许多甚至都是目击者的亲身经历，记录了 6 世纪后期墨洛温王朝统治下的高卢（Gaul）所发生的事情。所以，都尔的格雷戈里，汤姆，我在大学里研究过他。他是一位伟大的加洛-罗马（Gallo-Roman）作家，出身于某种元老阶层。这是一本绝妙的书。我知道你是这本书第一行的超级粉丝，那是整个历史上最伟大的一句话。是的，我想这是我写过的最喜欢的一句话。你想告诉大家这是什么吗？它太准确了。很多事情不断发生。其中有些是好的，有些是坏的。
I mean that's the whole of history there, isn't it? Yeah. Well this is one of the bad things. Definitely. So the rivalry between Fredegund and Brunhilde, which is the subject of today's episode, this extraordinary feud between these two formidable queens of the Franks. Yes. So let's start with Fredegund. Fredegund is the granddaughter-in-law of Clovis, who is the bloke we talked about last time,
我的意思是，这就是整部历史，对吧？是的。嗯，这是糟糕的事情之一。肯定的。所以弗蕾代贡德和布伦希尔德之间的争端，也就是今天这一集的主题，这两位法兰克人令人生畏的女王之间这场非同寻常的世仇。是的。那么让我们从弗蕾代贡德开始。弗蕾代贡德是克洛维（Clovis）的孙媳妇，克洛维就是我们上次谈到的人，
the founder of the Merovingian dynasty, master of what's becoming, was once Gaul, but is becoming under Frankish rule, or is going to become, France. And so actually is Brunhilde. But there's no question that Gregory of Tor, on whose account we chiefly depend for the lives of Fredegund and Brunhilde, he is absolutely team Brunhilde. She is never really accused of anything bad, whereas Fredegund, to Gregory, she is an absolute monster. So he accuses her of terrible crimes, multiple assassinations, witchcraft. He even accuses her of having murdered a bishop in his own cathedral and he has the bishop turn to Fredigan as he's
墨洛温王朝的奠基者，曾经是高卢、但在法兰克统治下正在变成或即将变成法国的这片土地的主人。布伦希尔德其实也是如此。但毫无疑问，我们主要依靠都尔的格雷戈里的记述来了解弗蕾代贡德和布伦希尔德的生活，他绝对是站在布伦希尔德这一边的。她从未真正被指控犯有任何罪行，而对于格雷戈里来说，弗蕾代贡德简直是一个绝对的怪物。因此，他指控她犯有可怕的罪行、多次暗杀和巫术。他甚至指控她在主教自己的大教堂里谋杀了一位主教，并且在主教
dying. He's been struck down by daggers, his blood is spilling out over the floor. As long as you live you will be accursed for God will avenge my blood upon your head. And does Fredigan care? She does not care at all. She just stands there and gloats. So I guess in Gregory's account, she is a baggage, but she might also seem what I believe Americans call a badass. Right. I mean, you could be both at once, surely. Or possibly just been badly misrepresented by a guy who just doesn't like her. Misunderstood. Yeah.
濒死时，主教转向弗蕾代贡德。他被匕首击中，鲜血流淌在地上。只要你活着，你就会受到诅咒，因为上帝会在你的头上为我的血复仇。弗蕾代贡德会在意吗？她一点也不在乎。她只是站在那里幸灾乐祸。所以我想在格雷戈里的叙述中，她是一个恶毒的女人，但她可能也符合美国人所说的狠角色。对吧。我的意思是，你肯定可以同时具备这两种特质。或者可能只是被一个根本不喜欢她的家伙严重歪曲了。被误解了。是的。
So we will discuss that. But I think two things are absolutely clear, even from Gregory's account of her, that her life is dominated by two things. And really important to keep these two goals in mind. One is she wants to see one of her sons rule as king and to see the end of her sister-in-law, Brunhilde. Right. And the feud between Fredegund and Brunhilde is not widely known, certainly in English speaking countries, but it absolutely bears comparison with that between Elizabeth
所以我们将会讨论这一点。但我认为有两件事是绝对清晰的，即使从格雷戈里对她的叙述来看，她的一生也被两件事所主导。将这两个目标牢记在心非常重要。一个是她希望看到自己的一个儿子作为国王统治，并看到她的嫂子布伦希尔德彻底倒台。没错。弗蕾代贡德和布伦希尔德之间的世仇并不广为人知，特别是在英语国家，但它绝对可以与伊丽莎白
I and Mary, Queen of Scots. I mean, in all kinds of ways, it's much more bloody and ferocious. And even though neither of them ruled as queen in her own right, though both are hailed by their admirers as queens. Their role is as wives and mothers of kings who, I mean, pretty much without exception, are vastly their inferiors in terms of ability. And the measure of that is the length of their rule. So Fredegund is queen, in inverted commas, for 29 29 years and Brünnhilde rules for an astonishing 46 years. Yeah, that's incredible. Yeah.
一世和苏格兰女王玛丽之间的恩怨相媲美。我的意思是，在各方面它都要血腥和残酷得多。尽管她们两人都没有以女王的身份直接统治，不过她们的仰慕者都尊称她们为女王。她们的角色是国王的妻子和母亲，而这些国王在能力方面几乎无一例外地远远不如她们。而这方面的衡量标准就是她们统治的时长。因此，弗蕾代贡德作为“女王”（加了引号）统治了 29 年，而布伦希尔德则统治了惊人的 46 年。是的，这太不可思议了。是的。
And it's not surprising that ultimately both of them end up as kind of figures of myth. So Brünnhilde in Wagner's opera, The Valkyrie, she's essentially a compound of the pair of them. In Miss, these two inveterate rivals are joined and united. All right, so Tom, let's just remind ourselves where we are for people who perhaps missed the last episode. We're in the ruins of the Western Roman Empire. The empire is still going in Constantinople in the Eastern Mediterranean, but in the Western half, the authority structures
最终她们两个人都变成某种神话人物，这并不令人意外。因此在瓦格纳的歌剧《女武神》（The Valkyrie）中，布伦希尔德基本上就是这两人结合的产物。在传说中，这两个根深蒂固的对手被合并并融为一体。好了，汤姆，让我们提醒一下大家，对于那些可能错过上一集的听众来说，我们现在身处何地。我们正处于西罗马帝国的废墟中。帝国在东地中海的君士坦丁堡仍在延续，但在西方，权力结构
have broken down and power has passed to these warlords who are now crowning themselves as kings and in Gaul that means the Franks under Clovis. And so someone like Fredegund, do we have a sense of when she's born? We're not absolutely sure when she's born, 530s, early 540s perhaps. Right. So about two generations after the end of the Western Roman Empire, approximately. Two generations after Clovis has made himself king. And the reason essentially why we don't know when Fredegund is born, and this is the remarkable thing about this woman who becomes such a powerful figure in Gaul, is that she seems to have begun her life as a slave. So I will quote
已经崩溃，权力已经移交给了这些军阀，他们现在正为自己加冕为王；在高卢，这意味着克洛维领导下的法兰克人。那么像弗蕾代贡德这样的人，我们知道她大致是什么时候出生的吗？我们不能完全确定她的出生时间，大约是在 530 年代或 540 年代初。没错。大约是西罗马帝国灭亡后两代人左右的时间。在克洛维自立为王之后大约两代人。基本上我们不知道弗蕾代贡德何时出生的原因——而对于这位在高卢成为如此有权势的人物女性来说，这是最引人注目的一点——那就是她似乎是以奴隶的身份开始人生的。所以我会引用
from The Dark Queens by Shelley Puhak, which is a wonderful account of the rivalry between these two queens, the great narrative account in English. She writes, where exactly had she come from? This Fredegund, this strawberry blonde slave queen, was she left on a doorstep, sold to satisfy a debt, or more likely captured as a child? We just don't know because the early details of a slave's life are lost to oblivion. But what we do know is that she is born at a terrible time in history. So what Michael McCormick, the great historian of the economy of late antiquity and early medieval Europe, describes as one of the worst periods to be alive. And the reason for that, we've actually kind of touched on this before, the mid sixth century is buffeted by natural disasters. So there's a volcanic eruption in 536, which is probably the decade that Fredegund is born,
雪莉·普哈克（Shelley Puhak）所著的《黑暗女王》（The Dark Queens）一书，这是一部精彩的英文纪实作品，讲述了这两位女王之间的恩怨。她写道：“她到底来自哪里？这位弗蕾代贡德，这位草莓金发的女奴女王，她是被遗弃在门阶上，为了偿还债务而被卖掉，还是更可能在童年时被俘虏？我们只是不知道，因为奴隶早年生活的细节已经湮没在遗忘中了。但我们所知道的是，她出生在历史上一个可怕的时期。”正如晚期古代和早期中世纪经济史巨匠迈克尔·麦考密克（Michael McCormick）所描述的那样，这是最不适宜生存的时期之一。其原因在于，我们之前其实也稍微触及过这一点，6 世纪中期受到了自然灾害的严重打击。公元 536 年发生了一场火山爆发，这很可能正是弗蕾代贡德出生的那十年，
and that sees temperatures drop by as much as two and a half degrees. Then you get the great plague, the Justinianic Plague, because it originates in the reign of the emperor Justinian, which sweeps eastwards and westwards as well. And you also have other epidemics and particularly epidemics of dysentery and these just keep hitting gall and Gregory of Tor writes of one in very moving terms. It attacked young children first of all, he writes, and to them it was fatal and so we lost our little ones
这导致气温下降了多达 2.5 度。接着迎来了大瘟疫，即查士丁尼大瘟疫（Justinianic Plague），因为它起源于皇帝查士丁尼统治时期，这场瘟疫向东和向西蔓延。此外还有其他流行病，特别是痢疾的流行，这些灾难不断袭击高卢。都尔的格雷戈里曾用非常感人的辞藻记录过其中一场瘟疫。他写道：“它首先袭击了小孩子，对他们来说这是致命的，因此我们失去了那些对我们如此挚爱、甜美可爱的小宝贝，我们曾将他们拥入怀中，抱在膝头，用如此慈爱的心去喂养和培育他们。当我写下这些时，我擦去了眼泪。”任何认为中世纪早期的人不关爱自己孩子的观点——我的情况是，这绝对证明了事实并非如此。而且绝对千真万确的是，儿童因痢疾而死将在整个故事中扮演关键角色，特别是在弗蕾代贡德的生活中。更糟糕的是，考虑到这是一个自然灾害、大流行病、权力崩塌、毫无疑问充满巨大恐惧的时代，
who were so dear to us and sweet whom we had cherished in our bosoms and dandled in our arms, whom we had fed and nurtured with such loving care. As I write, I wipe away the tears." And any notion that people in the early middle ages didn't care about their children, I mean, I think that that absolutely demonstrates that's not the case. And it is absolutely the case as well that the deaths of children by dysentery will play a key part in this story, particularly in the life of Fredigan. And what is worse, perhaps not surprisingly given that it's an age of natural disasters, of pandemics, of the breakdown of authority, tremendous fear, no doubt, it is an age of
这也是一个战争的时代，汤姆，因为法兰克人首先是战士。他们来了，他们曾为罗马军队效力。这就是他们所做的。这也是他们非常擅长的。这是他们懂得去做的事。是的。因此，我想人们会有这种感觉，你知道，这是黑暗时代，罗马帝国崩溃了。
war, Tom, because the Franks are warriors above all. They came, they were working for the Roman army. That's what they do. That's what they're very good at. That's what they know to do. Yeah. And so I think people would have the sense, you know, this is the Dark Ages, the Roman Empire's collapse.
这些都是军阀。到处都是无休止的暴力和混乱。我的意思是，需要强调的是，正如你刚才所说，这是一个战争的时代，但它是一种相当具有罗马风格的战争。法兰克国王实际上首先是罗马军事传统的继承者，因此高卢的军事传统是罗马人将他们的权力强加于莱茵河东岸，这正是法兰克国王所做的。因此，在征服高卢之后，他们便效仿罗马皇帝在整个罗马历史进程中所做的事情，即向德国派遣军事远征军。
These are warlords. It's just endless violence and things. I mean, the thing to emphasise is that what you've just said, that it is a time of war, but it's quite a Roman style of war. The Frankish kings are really the heirs above all to Rome's military traditions and so the military tradition in Gaul was for the Romans to impose their power on the eastern banks of the Rhine and so that is what the Frankish kings do. So having conquered Gaul they then do as the Roman emperors had done throughout the course of Roman history, which is to send military expeditions into Germany.
事实上，法兰克人这样做的方式比罗马人以往做过的更加有效。例如，在 531 年，克洛维的儿子、一个名叫克洛泰尔（Clothar）的人，征服了后来被称为图林根（Thuringia）的地区。这是一片广袤的德国东部土地。他将数量巨大的奴隶带回高卢。克洛泰尔是一位非常具有克洛维塑造风格的国王。他既是罗马人，又是野蛮人。他的生育能力也很强，有四个儿子，其中三个是一个妻子所生，另一个是另一个妻子所生。当他去世时，他将王国分成四份分给他们。
And actually the Franks do it in a way more effectively than the Romans ever did. So for instance, in 531, Clovis' son, a guy called Clothar, conquers the region that will come to be known as Thuringia. So a great swathe of East Germany. And he brings back enormous quantities of slaves to Gaul. And Clothar is a king very much in the mould of Clovis. He is simultaneously Roman and barbarian. He's also very fecund and he has four sons, three of them by one sister, one by another. And when he dies, he divides the kingdom up four ways between them.
我必须说，我以前一直认为法兰克国王将王国分给他们儿子的这种倾向是一种野蛮的习俗。但随后我读到了这一时期伟大历史学家帕特里克·吉里（Patrick Geary）对此的看法，他写道：“将王国在四个儿子之间进行分割的解决方案，与其说是法兰克人的，倒不如说是罗马人的做法。”所以，这再次体现了他表现得像个罗马人，而不是野蛮人。克洛泰尔的领土大致沿着罗马的政治边界进行划分，每个兄弟都在一座主要城市设立了自己的中心，并配有罗马顾问。当然，如果你仔细想想，罗马帝国不是一直在被不断地分割吗？
And I have to say that I always thought of this, this tendency of the Frankish kings to divide their kingdom up between their sons as being a barbarian practice. But then I read Patrick Geary, the great historian of this period on it, and he writes, the solution of dividing the kingdom among his four sons seems less a Frankish than a Roman one. So again, this idea that he's behaving like a Roman, not a barbarian. Clothar's territories were divided along roughly Roman political boundaries, and each brother was established with his own and Roman advisors centered in a major city. But of course, if you think about it, the Roman Empire was endlessly being divided up.
是的，从没成功过。这助长了战争。问题在于，完全相同的事情再次发生，你知道，这是克洛维之后的第三代人，克洛泰尔的这四个儿子，因为他们彼此之间相处得并不是很好。其中有一个人特别突出，他可以说是“一窝里的小不胎”，特别心怀怨恨，特别充满妒忌。这就是克洛泰尔最小的儿子，一个名叫希尔佩里克（Chilperic）的人。希尔佩里克不仅是年龄最小的，而且还是其他三个兄弟同父异母的兄弟。所以他是克洛泰尔第二个妻子的唯一儿子，而另一个妻子生下了那三个儿子。我也觉得这非常
Yeah, never worked. And this fostered war. And the problem is that exactly the same thing happens, you know, this third generation on from Clovis, these four sons of Clothar, because they don't necessarily get on with each other very well. And there was one of them in particular, who's the kind of, if you like, the runt of the litter, who is particularly embittered, particularly resentful. And this is the youngest of Clothar's sons, a guy who is called Chilperic. And Chilperic is not just the youngest, but also the half brother of the other three. And so he's the only son of Clothar's second wife, who's the sister of the other wife who's given him the three sons. And I think what's also very
《权力的游戏》，我的意思是，这是奇幻小说中的一个绝对老套的情节，即那个怀恨在心、满腹怨气的最小儿子也是最渴望把他的兄弟们挤开、夺走一切的人。总是最渴望權力也最冷酷无情。正是如此。因此，当他们的父亲去世时，希尔佩里克立即采取行动，试图夺取整个王国。他通过夺取巴黎——即首都——以及皇家国库来做到这一点。如果你控制了国库（这是可移动的，你知道，这是一个巨大的黄金和战利品储藏库），那么太棒了，你知道，你可以雇佣随从为你效劳。但他被他的兄弟们挫败了。在对高卢的瓜分中，他只得到了国家东北部的一块残余领地，而这里实际上一直是法兰克人的核心腹地。
Game of Thrones, I mean, it's an absolute kind of trope from fantasy fiction is that the youngest son who's bitter and resentful is also the keenest to try and elbow his brothers out the way and grab everything. Always the most hungry and ruthless. Exactly. So when their father dies, Chilperic immediately moves to try and seize the entire kingdom. And he does this by grabbing both Paris, so the capital, and the royal treasury. And if you control the treasury, which is mobile, you know, it's a kind of great repository of gold and loot, then brilliant, you know, you can employ men to follow you. But he's foiled by his brothers. And in the division of Gaul, he's left with this kind of rump of territory in the northeast of the country and this had actually been the old Frankish heartland.
所以苏瓦松（Soissons）是克洛维击败高卢最后一个罗马统治者西阿格里乌斯（Syagrius）的地方，苏瓦松成了希尔佩里克的主要大本营；这里还有亚眠（Amiens），圣马丁（Saint Martin）曾在这里割下自己的斗篷分给乞者一半；这里还有图尔奈（Tournai），希尔佩里克就安葬在那里，但这是四个王国中最小的一个，后来被法兰克人称为纽斯特里亚（Neustria），从法兰克语翻译过来意为“西方土地”。这是因为还有一个他们基本上从现在的德国境内雕刻出来的东方领土，被称为东方土地，即奥斯特拉西亚（Austrasia）。所以纽斯特里亚和奥斯特拉西亚，它们成为了极大的对手，不是吗？它们会的。而此时，奥斯特拉西亚比纽斯特里亚要大得多、大得多，
So Soissons was where Clovis had beaten Saagrius, the last Roman ruler in Gaul and Soissons becomes Chilpric's main base and there's Amiens where Saint Martin had cut his cloak and given half of it to the beggar, there's Torni where Chilpric was buried, but it is the smallest of the four kingdoms and it comes to be known by the Franks as Neustria, which translates from Frankish as the Western Lands. And this is because there's an Eastern territory which they have basically carved out of what's now Germany, which is called the Eastern Lands, which is Austrasia. So Neustria and Austrasia, they become great adversaries, don't they? They will. And at this point, Austrasia is much, much larger than Neustria,
以兰斯（Reims）、梅斯（Metz）、斯特拉斯堡（Strasbourg）为中心，由克洛泰尔四个儿子中的老三统治。这是一个名叫西吉贝尔特（Sigibert）的人。希尔佩里克厌恶西吉贝尔特，这部分可能是因为他们的年龄最相近，但也是因为他们有一条长达 300 英里的漫长边界，而希尔佩里克一直在针对西吉贝尔特进行种种谋划，极力想要将他拉下马。这就是弗蕾代贡德作为这个宏大权力游戏中一个玩家登场的背景。所以我们说过她是他府中的一名奴隶。没错，在希尔佩里克的府中。在希尔佩里克的府中。她完全处于社会的最底层。我们说过这是一个充满危险、瘟疫肆虐、战火纷飞的世界。
centered on Reuss, on Metz, on Strasbourg, and that is ruled by the third of Clothal's four sons. And here's a guy called Sigabert. And Chilperic detests Sigurdbert and that may be partly because they are the closest in age, but it's also because they have a long 300 mile border and Chilperic is endlessly maneuvering against Sigurdbert, desperate to kind of drag him down. And this is the background to the emergence of Fredegund as a player in this great game of thrones. So we said she's a slave in his household. Right, in Chilprick's household. In Chilprick's household. She's absolutely at the bottom of the pile. We've said it's a dangerous, plague-swept, war-torn world.
但我想，哪里有危险和动荡，哪里也就有机遇，特别是如果你是一个拥有非凡能力的女性——我认为即使都尔的格雷戈里也会承认弗蕾代贡德确实如此。所以她显然非常有性吸引力。我的意思是，这可能是她在其职业生涯之初带给这场博弈的最重要的单一属性。但她显然也非常非常聪明。因此，尽管她是个奴隶，她似乎还是自学了读写，并且学会了拉丁语和法兰克语。
But I guess that where there is peril and upheaval, there is also opportunity, particularly if you are a woman of remarkable abilities, which I think even Gregory of Tull would acknowledge Fredegund was. So she's clearly very sexually attractive. I mean, that is probably the single most important attribute that she brings to the party at the beginning of her career. But she's also clearly very, very intelligent. So even though she's a slave, she seems to have taught herself letters and also to speak Latin as well as Frankish.
她极其大胆，极其坚决。正如雪莉·普哈克所说的那样，我认为这非常精彩，她具备“打磨微小才能的能力，能够神不知鬼不觉地溜进溜出一个房间，能够凭直觉看出哪个厨子或随从最有可能说漏嘴一些绝密信息”。因此，在她的整个职业生涯中，她看透人心、操纵他人以及搜集秘密的能力，是她如何在将要定义她一生的所有军事事件中立于不败之地的关键部分。
She's incredibly daring, she's incredibly determined. And she also has, so Shelley Puhak puts this, I think think wonderfully, the honing of small talents, the ability to slip in and out of a room unnoticed to intuit which cook or lackey was likely to let slip a choice bit of information. So throughout her career, her ability to read people, to manipulate them, to pick up secrets, this is a key part of how she keeps on top of all the two military events that will typify her life.
哦，说到立于不败之地。有一个故事，不是吗，关于她是如何真正采取行动的，那就是她从厨房被提升为侍候女王的女仆。女王名叫阿尔德维拉（Aldevere）。然后基本上她设计陷害女王阿尔德维拉，让她与希尔佩里克大吵一架。接着她一直在背景中潜伏着。每日邮报在线版说，她在希尔佩里克面前大显身姿，后者基本上说：“行了，女王得走人，把她送到修道院去，今晚你跟我在一起。”
Well, talk about keeping on top of events. There's a story, isn't there, about how she actually makes her move, which is that she has been promoted from the kitchen to serve the Queen as her maid. The Queen's called Aldevere. And then basically she tricks the Queen, Aldevere, into into falling out into having a row with Chilperic. And then all the time she's kind of, you know, lurking in the background. The mail online say that she's flaunting her curves at Chilperic, who basically says, right, the Queen's got to go get her off to a convent, you know, you're with me tonight.
这完全是她一直以来精心策划的。是的。关于她从厨房晋升的故事发生得比较晚，可能给这段本身就很戏剧性的崛起过程镀上了一层传奇色彩。但我认为毫无疑问，正是她的曼妙身姿——如果你想这么说的话——吸引了希尔佩里克，而且这位女王阿尔德维拉确实被打发去了修道院，弗蕾代贡德确实成为了、你知道的，成为了主要的皇家妃嫔。但当然，成为妃嫔绝不意味着地位稳固，因为你是非常非常容易被取代的。
And that's exactly as she's planned it all along. Yes. The story about her being promoted from the kitchens, it's quite late and is maybe gilding the lily of the inherently kind of dramatic story of her rise. But I don't think there's any question that it is her curves, if you want to put it that way, that appeal to Chilperic and definitely that this queen out of error is packed off to a convent and Fredigan does become, you know, the kind become the chief royal concubine. But of course to be a concubine is absolutely not to be secure because you are very, very expendable.
而弗蕾代贡德面临的问题是，希尔佩里克不仅心怀怨恨且野心勃勃，而且非常非常任性。他绝对决心不惜一切代价冲出他被囚禁的那一小块高卢角落，并以一种地道的罗马方式大展身手。而且他显然有着公开的罗马野心。所以在他的所有兄弟中，据我们所知，他是唯一一个建造露天剧场并在其中上演类似罗马皇帝那种壮观场面的。想象一下这在 6 世纪的高卢、在罗马帝国在那里灭亡几十年后仍在继续，真是令人惊叹。但这同时也意味着他需要一位与他自认为应得的身份相称的女王。
And the problem for Fredegund is that Chilperic is not only resentful and ambitious, but he's also very, very willful. And he is absolutely determined to do whatever it takes to break out of this tiny corner of Gaul that he's been penned into and kind of strut his stuff in an authentically Roman way. And he clearly does have overtly Roman ambitions. So of all his brothers, he, so far as we know, is the only one who builds amphitheaters and stages spectacles in them like a Roman emperor. It's kind of amazing to think of this being carried on in sixth century Gaul, decades after the Roman Empire has fallen there. But it also means that he needs a queen who is
显然，一个女奴根本不够格。因此，在将弗蕾代贡德弄上床后不久，他已经在物色合适的新娘来取代阿尔德维拉，他看准了一个王国的公主，这个王国能够与墨洛温王朝相抗衡，那就是以西班牙为中心的西哥特王国（Visigoths）。同样是一个非常强大的蛮族王国。他施压迎娶西哥特公主的机会出现在 567 年，当时四个兄弟中最年长的一个、一个名叫夏贝尔特（Charibert）的人自然死亡。他的土地随后在三个幸存的兄弟之间进行瓜分。其结果是一个完全疯狂、无法运作的领地拼凑体。这有点像神圣罗马帝国。你知道，这里有一点城镇，
commensurate with the status that he thinks should be his. And clearly, a slave girl doesn't measure up at all. So not long after he's taken Fredegund into his bed, he's already looking around for a suitable bride to replace out of error and he fixes on a princess from the one kingdom that can rival that of the Merovingians and that's the kingdom of the Visigoths which is centered in Spain. Again a very powerful barbarian kingdom. And his chance to press for a Visigothic princess comes in 567 when the oldest of the four brothers, a guy called Charibert, dies of natural causes. And his lands are then divided up among the three surviving brothers. And the result is a kind of completely mad, unworkable patchwork of kind of territory. It's a bit like the Holy Roman Emperor. You know, bits of towns here,
那里有一块土地。所以巴黎保持中立。那是三个兄弟之间的一个安全空间。奥斯特拉西亚国王西吉贝尔特——也就是东部的那个大块区域——得到了卢瓦尔河（Loire），这显然与他的位置相反，其中包含图尔。哦，对了。所以他得到了圣马丁。是的。非常重要。最年长的幸存兄弟，也就是一个名叫贡特拉姆（Guntrum）的人，他的权力基地在勃艮第。他得到了阿基坦（Aquitaine），这同样位于高卢与他相对的另一侧。但对希尔佩里克来说最关键的是，你知道，他一直被困在北方，如果这就是他所能提供的全部，西哥特人根本不会搭理他。
chunks of land there. So Paris is left neutral. That's a kind of safe space between the three brothers. Sigurd Burt, who's the king of Australia, so that's the kind of the eastern chunk. He gets the Loire, which is obviously the opposite end from him, and that includes Tor. Oh, right. So he gets St Martin. Yeah. So very important. The eldest surviving brother, so this is a guy called Guntrum, his power base is in Burgundy. He gets Aquitaine, which again is on the opposite side of Gaul from him. But the key thing for Chilperic, you know, he's been penned in in the north and there's no way that the Visigoths would give him the time of day if that was all he had to offer.
他的统治范围沿着整个海峡一直延伸到保持独立的布列塔尼（Brittany）。但他同时也获得了西南部高卢的大部分地区，这当然与比利牛斯山脉接壤，这意味着西班牙。因此，这确实使他成为西哥特人感兴趣的人物。起初，在夏贝尔特死后他获得了所有这些新土地的余波中，他恢复了老一套的伎俩。他试图夺取图尔，因为那里有圣马丁的陵墓，实在太重要了，但西吉贝尔特设法击退了他。但随后他与西哥特人开启了婚姻谈判，并且如愿以偿。他得到了一位公主。于是在 568 年，西哥特国王的长女、一位名叫
His sway is extended all along the line of the channel as far as Brittany, which remains independent. But he also gets most of southwestern Gaul and that of course abuts the Pyrenees, which means Spain. And so that does make him a person of interest to the Physigoths. Initially, in the wake of Charibert's death and his getting all these new lands, he gets up to his normal tricks. He tries to grab Tor because with its tomb of St. Martin, it's so important, but Sigurd manages to beat him off. But then he opens marriage negotiations with the Visigoths and he gets what he wants. He gets a princess. And in 568, the eldest daughter of the king of the Visigoths, a princess called
加尔斯温萨（Galswintha）的公主，正式从西班牙向北出发前往纽斯特里亚，她抵达了塞纳河畔。她顺流而上，有点像玛丽·安托瓦内特（Marie Antoinette）当年那样，她走下船，受到希尔佩里克及其全军屈膝跪迎。他带他们出来作为一种荣誉的姿态。这真是一个非常《权力的游戏》式的场景，不是吗？非常是的，都尔的格雷戈里描述了这个感人和浪漫的时刻：“希尔佩里克国王非常深爱她，因为她带来了一笔巨额嫁妆。”有什么不喜欢的呢？金钱能为他买来爱情。是的。
Galzwintha, duly sets off from Spain northwards to Neustria and she arrives on the banks of the Seine. She's come up the river, a bit like Marie Antoinette did, and she steps out from the boat and she's greeted on bended knee by Chilperic and his entire army. He's brought them out as a gesture of honor. That's a very Game of Thrones scene isn't it? Very and Gregory of Tor describes this moving and romantic moment. King Chilperic loved her very dearly for she had brought a huge dowry with her. What's not to like? Money can buy him love. Yeah.
但弗蕾代贡德对此作何感想？因为她一直和国王共度春宵，对于这个西哥特公主的突然出现，她绝不会感到高兴。这对弗蕾代贡德来说是非常非常糟糕的消息。有关希尔佩里克对她热情的报告已经传到了西哥特人那里。因此，这成为了婚姻谈判中的一个具体条款：希尔佩里克必须把她踢开，除了西哥特公主加尔斯温萨之外，不能再有任何其他女人。所以希尔佩里克真的很想要这位公主，于是他把弗蕾代贡德给踢开了，你知道，她失去了
But what does Fredigan make of this? Because she's been sharing the royal beds. She can't be best pleased that this Visigothic princess has pitched up. It's very, very bad news for Fredigan because reports of Chilperic's enthusiasm for her have reached the Visigoths. And so it's become a specific clause in the marriage negotiations that Chilperic will chuck her out and not have any other woman other than Galswinter, the Visigothic princess. So Chilperic really wants this princess so he's chucked Fredegund out, you know, she loses
皇家情妇的地位，但她并没有大发雷霆、危及她与希尔佩里克的关系，而是回到了她以前的职责岗位上去。但正如雪莉·普哈克所说的那样，“她确保希尔佩里克在走廊和庭院里能瞥见她的身影，这是对一段更轻松、更幸福时光的诱人提醒。”所以她仍然在炫耀她曼妙的身姿。事实证明，希尔佩里克根本无法抗拒她。你知道，她对他来说是不可抗拒的。因此，在婚礼几个月后，加尔斯温萨发现希尔佩里克正与弗蕾代贡德同床共枕，于是爆发了一场极其激烈的争吵。加尔斯温萨威胁要返回西班牙，这显然会让希尔佩里克颜面扫地。一天早晨，加尔斯温萨被发现死在她的床上，她被勒死了。都尔的格雷戈里
her status as the royal mistress and rather than kind of throw a hissy fit and risk her relationship with Chilperic, she goes back to her former duties. But as Shelley Puhak puts it, she made sure Chilperic caught glimpses of her in passageways and courtyards, enticing reminders of an easier and more blissful time. So she is still flaunting her curves. And it turns out, Chilperic can't resist her. You know, she is irresistible to him. And so a few months after the wedding, Galswinter finds Chilperic in bed with Fredegund and there's an absolutely massive row. Galswinter threatens to leave for Spain, which would obviously be mortifying for Chilperic. One morning, Gal-Swinther is found in her bed and she has been strangled. And Gregory
写道：“希尔佩里克国王为他的女王之死痛哭流涕，但几天后，他去了教堂，在那里，在圣坛前，身穿华丽珠宝、披着王室伴侣长袍的人正是弗蕾代贡德，他们结婚了。”这场丑闻在高卢回荡，在整个基督教世界回荡。当然，每个人都在想着都尔的格雷戈里用言语表达出的想法：是希尔佩里克下令让他的一个仆人勒死了加尔斯温萨。天哪，这真是一个震惊的消息。重磅炸弹。一枚真正的重磅炸弹。
of Tor writes, King Chilperic wept for the death of his queen, but then a few days later, he goes to the church and there at the altar, dressed in splendid jewels in the robes of a royal partner is Fredegund and they get married. And the scandal of it echoes across Gaul, it echoes across Christendom. And everyone of course is thinking what Gregory of Tor puts into words, it was Chilperic who had ordered Galswina to be garroted by one of his servants. Craigie, so that is a shock. Bombshell. A real bombshell.
整个法兰克世界对此有何反应？人们是在说：“哦，做得好，这是合理的行为”，还是这会让希尔佩里克和弗蕾代贡德成为众矢之的？嗯，反响特别强烈的地方是在奥斯特拉西亚宫廷，希尔佩里克的兄弟西吉贝尔特是那里的国王。其原因、为什么在那里产生如此强烈的反响，部分原因是因为西吉贝尔特和希尔佩里克确实深恶痛绝对方。但也是因为西吉贝尔特也娶了一位西哥特女王。
And what's the reaction across the sort of Frankish world? So do people say, oh, good on you, this is reasonable behaviour or is this going to make Chilperic and Fredegund horriers? Well, the place where it particularly reverberates is in the court of Australia where Chilperic's brother Sigurdbert is king. And the reason for that, why it particularly reverberates there is partly because Sigurdbert and Chilperic really detest each other. But it's also because Sigurdbert is also married to a Visigothic queen.
这位女王是加尔斯温萨的亲妹妹，也就是刚刚被谋杀的那位公主。她前一年，即 567 年，就已经抵达了奥斯特拉西亚。嫁给西吉贝尔特的这位西哥特公主的名字叫做多米尼克·布伦希尔德。好吧，现在我们有了这场戏剧中的另一个伟大主角——布伦希尔德。我们有了。现在我们显然可以理解为什么布伦希尔德对弗蕾代贡德充满极度的鄙视，反之亦然，因为布伦希尔德显然永远不会原谅她杀害了她的妹妹。但我们已经谈过了弗蕾代贡德。
And this queen is the younger sister of Galsmyntha, so the princess who's just been murdered. She had arrived in Austrasia the year before, so in 567. The name of this princess, this Visigothic princess married to Sykebert is Dominic Brunhilde. Okay, so now we've got the other great player in the drama, Brunhilde. We have. Now we can obviously understand why Brunhilde absolutely despises Fredegund and vice versa because Brunhilde clearly is never going to forgive her for the death of her sister. But we've talked about Fredegund.
布伦希尔德本人也是一个非常了不起的女性，不是吗？她非常时髦，非常美丽，非常优雅，并且精通政治。她确实如此，非常像弗蕾代贡德。所以她处境艰难，她是法兰克宫廷里的外国人，但她已经在短短一年内证明了自己是一个非常精明、非常强硬的政治运作高手，并且她特意与西吉贝尔特宫廷中的主要权贵们结成了联盟。所以这是
Brunhilde herself is a pretty remarkable woman, isn't she? She's incredibly fashionable, she's very beautiful, she's very elegant and she's brilliant at politics. She really is, very like Fredagund. So she's in a difficult situation, she's a foreigner in a Frankish court, but she's already in the space of a year showed herself to be a very shrewd, a very tough political operator and she's made a point of forging alliances with the kind of, you know, the leading men at Sigabert's court. So that's
她所做的一件事。但她做的最关键的事——这也是丈夫们认为王后们存在的主要目的——就是她履行了她首要的职责，那就是为西吉贝尔特生了一个儿子。西吉贝尔特的儿子名叫希尔德贝特（Childebert），他在复活节出生。他在基督教大节日五旬节受洗。这在奥斯特拉西亚的所有人看来，都是上帝恩宠的绝对标志。因此，布伦希尔德在奥斯特拉西亚人人交口称赞。她对西吉贝尔特说：“听着，我的妹妹被你兄弟的情妇谋杀了，而那个情妇现在正穿着我死去的妹妹的长袍和衣服四处招摇过市。
one thing that she's done. But the key thing she's done, and it's what basically queens are there for in the opinion of their husbands, is that she's fulfilled her prime duty, which is to give Sigabert a son. And Sigabert's son is called Childebert, and he is born at Easter. He's baptized at the great Christian Festival of Pentecost. And this seems to everyone in Australia an absolute marker of divine favor. So Brunhilde is very much in everyone's good books in Australia. And she works on Sigurdbert and says, look, my sister has been murdered by your brother's mistress who is now kind of posing around in my dead sister's robes and clothes.
这是不可容忍的。你知道，你必须复仇。”说实话，我认为这是一个合理的立场。我认为是的。是的，我想是的。因此，西吉贝尔特转向他的兄弟、勃艮第国王贡特拉姆——也就是年长的兄弟——说：“听着，我们把这件事闹到法庭上去吧。你应该传唤希尔佩里克来对这起显然是可怕的罪行负责，我们要审判他，以便一切都光明正大。”贡特拉姆说：“好吧，很有道理。显然发生了可怕的事情。我们需要弄清真相。”于是贡特拉姆传唤希尔佩里克前来受审，而希尔佩里克拒绝了。
And this is unsupportable. You know, you have to have vengeance. I think that's a reasonable position to be fair. I think it is. Yeah, I think it is. And so Sigurd Burt, he turns to his brother Guntrum, the king of Burgundy, so the elder brother, and he says, look, let's take this to trial. You should summon Chilperic to answer for what is clearly a terrible crime and we will try him so that everything will be above board. And Guntrim says, yeah, fair enough. Clearly something terrible has happened. We need to get to the bottom of this. So Guntrim summons to Chilperic to come and stand trial and Chilperic refuses.
因此他在缺席的情况下受到审判并被判有罪。这当然为西吉贝尔特入侵纽斯特里亚提供了完美的法律和宗教制裁，并且知道高卢的每个人基本都会站在他这一边。他的身边有贡特拉姆支持，有他所有的追随者支持，而且他在纽斯特里亚也有相当多的人，他们当然对他们的国王可能犯下的罪行感到非常担忧。他们也很倾向于倒戈投向他。因此，当他在 575 年发起战役时，这是一场绝对的胜利。
So he's tried in absentia and found guilty. And this of course then provides Zygabert with the perfect legal religious sanction to invade Neustria and know that everyone in Gaul basically will be on his side. He's got Gunnström on his side, he's got all his own followers on his side, and he's got quite a lot of people in Neustria who are of course very anxious about the crime that their king might have committed. They are also very prone to go over to him. And so when he launches his campaign in 575, it's an absolute triumph.
希尔佩里克和弗蕾代贡德被迫逃离他们的首都苏瓦松。他们不得不随身带走所有的宝藏；你知道，他们冒不起失去这些宝藏的风险。他们还放弃了希尔佩里克曾经占领的巴黎。西吉贝尔特迁入巴黎——墨洛温王朝奠基者克洛维埋葬的地方，他召来了布伦希尔德、他的小男孩希尔德贝特以及布伦希尔德到此已经生下的几个女儿。于是全家人搬到了巴黎，搬进了位于西岱岛（Île de la Cité）的大宫殿，
Chilperic and Fredegund are forced to flee Soissons, their capital. They have to take all their treasure with them. You know, they can't risk losing that. They also abandoned Paris, which Chilperic had occupied. Sigurdbert moves into Paris, the place where Clovis, the founder of the Merovingian dynasty, is buried and he summons Brunhilde and his little boy Childebert and various daughters who Brunhilde has also given birth to by this point. And so the whole family, they move to Paris, they move into the great palace on the Yield to Paris and
巴黎主教尊称布伦希尔德为“最卓越女王”（praecellentissima regina）。因此，她在墨洛温王朝的腹地被尊为女王，这看起来棒极了。与此同时，在纽斯特里亚，所有的贵族都开始向西吉贝尔特叛变，于是西吉贝尔特决定北上去见他们。他把布伦希尔德和他的孩子们留在巴黎。他向北进发。他来到了希尔佩里克的某座皇家别墅，纽斯特里亚的所有贵族都在那里集结了。
the Bishop of Paris hails Brunhilde as praecellentissima regina, the most excellent queen. So she is being hailed as queen in the very heart of the Merovingian dynasty and this is looking brilliant. And meanwhile out in Noistria all the nobles are starting to defect to Sigurdbert and so Sigurdbert decides he will go north and meet them. He leaves Brunhilde and his children behind in Paris. He goes northwards. He goes to one of Chilperic's royal villas where all the nobility of Neustria have assembled.
奥斯特拉西亚的贵族也加入了他们。这是一场规模宏大的集会。他们欢呼西吉贝尔特为王，将他举到盾牌上，在队伍中游行，看起来希尔佩里克和弗蕾代贡德简直是在劫难逃了。但多米尼克，那就太低估弗蕾代贡德的决心和狡猾了。对的，因为如果这是《权力的游戏》，这就好象史坦尼斯·拜拉席恩（Stannis Baratheon）看起来要接管王国时出现了一个巨大的反转。所以，这一切看起来太好了，总会有一些意料之外的故事发展，
The nobility of Austrasia join them. There's a massive great assembly. They hail Sigurd Berta's king, he's lifted up onto a shield, he's paraded through their ranks and it seems that Chilperic and Fredegund are absolutely doomed. But that, Dominic, is to reckon without Fredegund's determination and cunning. Right, because if this was Game of Thrones, it's like when Redley Baratheon looks like he's going to take over the kingdom and there's a great twist. So, you know, it's all looking too good. There would be some unexpected narrative
会稍微挑战一下人们的信任度，但它却又实实在在是真实发生的。或许就有什么类似的事情正在逼近。好吧，让我们拭目以待。所以，西吉贝尔特已经在盾牌上游行示众。两个王国的贵族都欢呼了他。一切看起来都太棒了。于是他从盾牌上走下来。他在自己的营地里闲逛，这时走过来两个小男孩。他们个子非常小。看上去完全没有任何威胁。他们显然是奴隶。从他们的穿着就能看出来。他们没有盔甲，也没有真正的武器，除了每个人在高卢都作为日常标配佩戴在腰带上的、比较钝的狩猎刀。
development that would slightly strain credulity but would nevertheless be true. And there's something like that just looming around the corner maybe. Well let's find out. So, Sigurd has been paraded around in his shield. All the nobles of the two kingdoms have hailed him. It's all looking brilliant. So he steps down from his shield. He's kind of wandering around his camp and he is approached by two young boys and they're very small. They look to be no threat whatsoever. They're clearly slaves. You can tell that from their dress. They have no armor, no real weapons, apart from pretty blunt hunting knives
所以他们看起来毫无威胁。他们在他的面前跪下，说他们有话要传达给。因此西吉贝尔特停下脚步，等着听他们说些什么，而他们却伸手去拿匕首，
that everyone, as a matter of course, in Gaul kind of wear on their belts. So they seem to be no threat at all. And they kneel before him and say that they have a message for him. And so Sigurdbert stops, waits to hear what they have to say, and they reach for their knives
都尔的格雷戈里告诉我们，他们从两侧刺向他。但这些都是相当钝的刀，本不至于杀死他。但西吉贝尔特，尽管他实际上只受了一点擦伤，但在几分钟内他就瘫倒在地上，开始口吐白沫，并在几小时内死亡。很明显，这些刀上淬了毒，而在高卢，究竟有谁有能力懂得如何掌控毒药、有胆量想出这样的阴谋，又有足够的说服力让两个男孩牺牲自己——因为他们当然立刻被处死了——人们的推测是，符合这一条件的只有一个人，而那个人，多米尼克，就是弗蕾代贡德。
and they strike him on both sides, Gregory of Tor tells us. But these are pretty blunt knives, it shouldn't be enough to kill him. But Sigurd, even though he's really only got a kind of scratch, within minutes he has collapsed onto the ground, starts to froth at the mouth and within hours he's dead. And it's clear the knives were poisoned and who in Gaul would have had the ability to know how to command poisons, the daring to come up with such a scheme, the powers of persuasion to get two boys to sacrifice themselves because of course they're immediately put to death. And the assumption is that there is only one person who fits that bill and that person Dominic is Fredigan.
多么惊天大反转。休息过后，我们回来揭晓接下来会发生什么。墨洛温王朝的妻子。计时器上只剩最后 30 秒，主队在通过永明金融（Sun Life）的人寿保险保障了家庭之后，正充满信心地向前推进。哇，真是个精彩的配合！加里，这可真叫平稳过渡啊。他们的保障工作显然做得滴水不漏。作为多伦多猛龙队的骄傲人寿保险合作伙伴，多年来我们见证了永明金融的大力支持，各位。
What a twist. Come back after the break to find out what happens next. The wife of a merivision. Just 30 seconds left on the clock and the home team is moving forward confidently after securing the family with life insurance from Sun Life. Wow, what a play! Talk about a smooth transition, Gary. They clearly have their coverage in check. As the proud life insurance partner, the Toronto Raptors, we've seen a lot of support from Sun Life over the years, folks.
太棒了，加尔。看来永明金融是你可以信赖的队友。前往 sunlife.ca 获取你的人生比赛计划，并保护最重要的一切。首先是坏消息。SAP 商务人工智能（SAP Business AI）无法帮您生成全家福度假照片的立体主义版本，但它将帮助您了解哪个供应商最适合协助您在东南亚推广植物基包装。识别您的初级项目经理晋升所需接受的培训。并在您专注于重大创新时，实现重复性任务的自动化，
Great stuff, Gar. Looks like Sun Life is the teammate you can trust. Head over to sunlife.ca to get your game plan for life and protect what matters most. First, the bad news. SAP Business AI won't help you generate Cubist versions of your family's holiday photos, but it will help you understand which supplier is best to help you roll out your plant-based packaging in Southeast Asia. Identify the training your junior project manager needs to rise up the ranks. And automate repetitive tasks while you focus on big innovations,
太棒了，加尔。看来永明金融是你值得信赖的合作伙伴。访问 sunlife.ca 制定您的人生比赛计划并保护最重要的事情。首先，是坏消息。SAP 业务人工智能不会帮你生成你家人节日照片的立体主义版本，但它会帮你了解哪个供应商最适合帮助你在东南亚推出植物基包装。识别你的初级项目经理晋升所需的培训。并在你专注于重大创新的同时自动化重复性任务，
so you can be ready for the next opportunity. Revolutionary technology, real world results. That's SAP Business AI. Winners and home sets bring you Save the Holidays, a race to slay the season, drama, romance, deals. A story that shows it's never too late to enjoy five-star savings on new gifts arriving daily. Christmas is coming and time is running out. Save your holiday with winners and home sense.
这样您就能为下一个机遇做好准备。革新科技，真实成果。这就是 SAP Business AI。Winners 和 Homesense 为您呈献“拯救假期”（Save the Holidays）：一场击败节日季的竞速，交织着戏剧、浪漫与优惠。这个故事展现了在每天送达的新礼品上享受五星级优惠永远都不会太迟。圣诞节将至，时间无多。让 Winners 和 Homesense 拯救您的假期。
King enjoyed a position both dependent and precarious, resting as it did on her personal sexual association with a husband whose interests or fancy could all too easily attach him to her supplanter. Even if the royal bride was, as occasionally in the 6th century, a foreign princess, her situation in practice might be little different from the ex-serving maids. Her dependence on her husband's generosity and favour, when her own kin were far away and her people reckoned perhaps the enemies of the Franks might be similarly complete. So Tom, that's a story called Janet L Nelson writing in an article, I assume, called Queens as Jezebels. Why do you like that reading? Well, I think it provides the academic perspective on all these shenanigans and it also sums
国王享受着一种既依赖又危险的地位，因为这种地位建立在她与一个丈夫的个人性爱关系上，而这个丈夫的利益或喜好很容易就会使他转向她的替代者。即使这位王后像6世纪时偶尔出现的那样是一位外国公主，她在实践中的处境可能也与那些退役的宫女没有什么不同。她对丈夫的慷慨和恩宠的依赖，当她自己的亲属远在天边，她的人民甚至可能被视为法兰克人的敌人时，这种依赖就更加彻底了。所以，汤姆，这就是简·L·纳尔逊（Janet L Nelson）在一篇我猜题为《作为耶洗贝尔的王后们》的文章中写的一个故事。你为什么喜欢这篇读物？嗯，我认为它为所有这些闹剧提供了学术视角，它还总结
up why Fredegund and Brunhilde, one a slave girl, one a princess, are actually, you know, you can reckon them worthy adversaries because the princess, like the slave girl, faces incredibly daunting challenges. And that is what makes it so amazing that their feud, it endures decades. But their struggles, I guess, are not only against each other, but also the circumstances that both of them, as the most powerful woman in their respective kingdoms, are facing as women. And even though we can't follow every twist and turn of their rivalry, I think the details, the kind of the broad outline that we'll go through in the second half. I mean it's so extraordinary, so kind of jaw-dropping
了为什么弗蕾德贡德和布伦希尔德——一个是奴隶女孩，一个是公主——实际上，你知道，你可以认为她们是旗鼓相当的对手，因为公主和奴隶女孩一样，面临着令人难以置信的严峻挑战。这就是为什么她们的长达数十年的宿怨如此令人惊叹。但我想，她们的斗争不仅是针对彼此，也是针对她们两人作为各自王国中最有权势的女性所面临的环境。尽管我们无法跟进她们竞争中的每一个曲折，但我认为在下半部分中我们将要探讨的那些细节、大致轮廓，我的意思是它是如此非凡，在某些点上
at points that it will become clear just how remarkable both these figures are, both these women are. So let's go with Fredrigan first because we ended with her apparently assassinating Sigurdbert. So that is a tremendous coup. Like she's basically wiped out the bloke who was the single biggest threat to her and her husband. And now, you know, she was staring into the abyss and now everything is possible again. Yeah. I mean, we don't know for sure that she did it, but she definitely benefits from it. And as we will see, it does have her kind of fingerprints all over it. So she's clawed everything back, both for herself and for Chilperic because with Sigurdbert
令人惊叹，以至于这两位人物、这两位女性是多么非凡，将会变得显而易见。所以我们先从弗蕾德贡德开始，因为我们以她显然暗杀西吉贝尔特作为结束。所以这是一个巨大的政变。就像她基本上消灭了对她和她丈夫构成最大威胁的那个家伙一样。现在，你知道，她曾凝视着深渊，而现在一切皆有可能了。是的。我的意思是，我们不确定是不是她干的，但她绝对从中受益了。正如我们将看到的，这确实留下了她的一点指纹。所以她把一切都夺回来了，无论是为了她自己还是为了希尔佩里克，因为西吉贝尔特
gone his heir, Chilterbert, is, I mean, you know, is a little boy about five years old, so no conceivable threat. And all the Neustrian nobles who had pledged their loyalty to Sigurdbert, you know, they think, well, we're not going to pledge our loyalty to a foreign child. So they immediately swing back to Chilperic and actually some of the Australians do as well, so the nobles who'd been following Zigebert and the vast mass of the Australians, the nobility, the men-at-arms who've been following them, they all withdraw to home territory. They feel there's no point in carrying on this war. And I think one of the reasons for thinking that Fredegund is behind
一死，他的继承人希尔德贝特，我的意思是，你知道是一个大约五岁的、根本构不成威胁的小男孩。所有那些曾向西吉贝尔特宣誓效忠的纽斯特利亚贵族，你知道，他们心想，好吧，我们不会向一个外国小孩子宣誓效忠。所以他们立即倒向希尔佩里克，实际上一些奥斯特拉西亚人也这样做了——所以那些曾追随西吉贝尔特的贵族，以及绝大多数奥斯特拉西亚人、贵族、追随他们的武装人员，他们全都撤回了本土。他们觉得再继续这场战争已经没有意义了。我认为认为弗蕾德贡德是幕后黑手的理由之一是，
this is that Chilperic from this point on seems to have treated her with an unusual degree of respect and devotion, almost as though he's kind of acknowledging what he owes her. And not only, I think, does he recognise that he's found in Fredegund a partner for his own ambitions, similarly kind of determined and ruthless. But also Fredegund, like Brunnhilde has done, has provided sons, so two in Fredegund's case. And so her position now seems completely secure. She's completely reversed the seeming abyss that she was about to fall into. She is now looking at kind of very solidly ensconced as the most powerful woman in Neustria,
希尔佩里克从这时起似乎对她表现出了异乎寻常的尊重和 devotion（深情），几乎就像是在承认他欠她的一样。而且我认为，不仅他认识到自己在弗蕾德贡德身上找到了一个符合自己雄心的伙伴，同样坚定且冷酷无情；而且弗蕾德贡德，就像布伦希尔德所做的那样，为他生下了儿子，在弗蕾德贡德的情况下是两个。因此，她现在的地位似乎完全稳固了。她彻底扭转了自己原本即将坠入的看似无底的深渊。她现在看起来非常稳固地确立了自己作为纽斯特利亚最具权势女人的地位，
which isn't to deny that the assassination of Sigurd comes with pretty high costs for her. So she is now seen not just as a slave, but as treacherous, as cowardly, as underhand. Actually for Franks, this is the epitome of what it is to be a slave and for what it is to be a woman. So Fredegund in that sense is the kind of the embodiment of everything that they most fear and despise. But Gregory of Tor, who is absolutely as we said, team Brunhilde, he goes further and accuses Fredegund of having practiced witchcraft. How else would she have known to apply the right amount of poison? How else would she have been able to suborn these two boys
这并不是要否认西吉之死给她带来了相当高昂的代价。所以她现在不仅被视为一个奴隶，而且被视为背信弃义、懦弱、阴险的代名词。实际上对法兰克人来说，这就是奴隶和女性的缩影。因此，从这个意义上说，弗蕾德贡德是他们最恐惧和鄙视的一切的化身。但是都尔的格里戈里，正如我们所说，绝对是布伦希尔德阵营的，他走得更远，指控弗蕾德贡德曾经练习巫术。否则她怎么会知道使用适量的毒药？否则她怎么能买通这两个显然走向死亡的男孩呢？这是一个非常严重的指控。因此，谢莉·普哈克（Shelley Puhack）在其精彩的著作《黑暗女王》（The Dark Queens）中指出，在高卢，诽谤一个女性为妓女的罚款是45索利迪（solidi）。
who were clearly going to their deaths? And this is a very serious charge. So Shelley Puhack in her wonderful book, The Dark Queens, points out that the fine in Gaul for slandering a woman as a whore was 45 solidi. I'm not quite sure exactly what that is, but respectable amount, I guess. But if you falsely accuse a woman of witchcraft, then the fine you have to pay is 187 and a
我不太清楚这具体是多少，但我想是一笔可观的数额。但如果你虚假指控一个女性犯有巫术，那么你必须支付的罚款是187个半索利迪。所以，你知道，这是一种相当大的失衡。是的，绝对是四倍多。那么弗蕾德贡德在乎吗？弗蕾德贡德似乎并不在乎，希尔佩里克也一样。在他们生命的任何时候，据我们所知，他们两个都从未屈尊回应针对他们的指控。他们从不否认自己犯下了谋杀罪，从不否认自己练习过巫术。我想弗蕾德贡德觉得被人畏惧总好过被人喜爱，她确实也变得令人畏惧了。那布伦希尔德呢？因为在上半部分结束时她看起来棒极了。
half solidy. So, you know, that's quite an imbalance. Yeah, definitely four times more. So does Fredigan care? Fredigan does not seem to have cared and neither really does Chilprick at no point in their lives, so far as we know, do either of them ever deign to respond to the accusations that are levelled against them. They never deny having committed murder, they never deny having practiced witchcraft. And I guess Fredegund feels that it's better to be feared than to be loved and she certainly does become feared. And what about Brunhilde? Because she was looking great at the end of the first half.
她被留在巴黎，一切都很好。然后她的丈夫被这两个男孩杀害了。她所有的希望都化为乌有了，对吧？她突然陷入了孤立无援的境地。是的。所以弗蕾德贡德从零变成了英雄，而布伦希尔德则从英雄变成了零。她被滞留在巴黎。她被充满敌意的人民包围着。当然，她的首要任务是确保她的儿子希尔德贝特的生存，因为她未来的这一切都取决于他的生还。根据传统，她把他装进一个袋子里，把他从宫殿偷运到一条船上，渡过塞纳河，他们设法把他带回了奥斯特拉西亚。
She was left in Paris, all was good. And then her husband has been killed by these two boys. And all her hopes have crumbled away to nothing, right? She's suddenly stranded and alone. Yeah. So Fredegund has gone from zero to hero and Brunhilde has gone from hero to zero. She has been left stranded in Paris. She's surrounded by a hostile population. And her priority, of course, is to ensure the survival of her son, Childebert, because everything for her future depends on him living. According to tradition, she puts him into a bag and smuggles him out of the palace into a boat, crosses the Seine, and they manage to get him back to Australia.
果然，希尔德贝特尽管只有大约五岁左右，还是在575年的圣诞节在奥斯特拉西亚加冕了，所以他——至少那是布伦希尔德可以抓住的一点慰藉。但对她来说，情况看起来非常糟糕，因为她落入了希尔佩里克的手中，而他对他一贯不想要的女人所做的就是把她打发到修道院去。那是一个位于鲁昂的非常特殊的修道院，有大量的石头，受到高度保护。所以它实际上是一座监狱。这就是他送阿尔德维拉去的地方，他的第一任妻子，也就是被弗蕾德贡德取代的那位。这是一个可怕的地方。
And sure enough Childerbert even though he's kind of only five or whatever, he's crowned in Austrasia on Christmas Day 575 so he at least that's something that Brunhilde can cling on to. But for her things are looking very bad because she has fallen into Childerbert's hands and he does what he always does to unwanted women, which is to pack her off to a convent. And it's a very particular convent in Rouen, great masses of stone, very highly protected. So it's effectively a prison. And this is where he sent Al De Vera, his first wife, the one that Fredegund had supplanted. And it's a terrible place.
这里是完全隐修的，你知道的，没有仆人，你必须穿着粗糙的长袍，你得留着规定样式的布丁碗发型。这绝不是布伦希尔德喜欢的生活方式。她在四处寻找逃跑的机会。于是她开始和阿尔德维拉交谈，他们显然互相交流了弗蕾德贡德是多么可怕的人的看法，而与阿尔德维拉的交谈给了布伦希尔德一个关于她如何逃跑的想法，这个想法在第二年春天，即576年春天变成了现实，那年春天，纽斯特利亚人的军队抵达了鲁昂，它由希尔佩里克的大儿子率领，他的名字叫梅罗维奇（Merovitch），就像海怪的名字一样。他是阿尔德维拉两个幸存的儿子之一，他奉父亲希尔佩里克的命令，向卢瓦尔河畔的奥斯特拉西亚领地进军，那将
It's fully cloistered. you know, there are no servants, you have to wear rough coarse robes, you have a regulation pudding bowl haircut. It's not at all Brunhilde's scene in any way. And she's looking around for opportunities to escape. And so she starts talking to Aldebarra and they obviously swap notes about what a terrible person Fredegund is and talking to Auld of Ere gives Brunhilde an idea about how she can escape and this idea becomes manifest in the spring of the following year, so 576 and that spring the army of the Noistrians arrives in Rouen and it is led by Chilperic's eldest son who is called Merovitch, so as in the sea monster. And he is one of two surviving sons of Audevara and he has been ordered by his father Chilperic to march on the Australian holdings in the Loire, so that would
包括都尔。但梅罗维奇直接违抗了这些命令，反而去了鲁昂。他声称那是去探望他的母亲阿尔德维拉，但很明显，他的真正目标是布伦希尔德。而且很明显，布伦希尔德写信给他并说：“听着，我们为什么不结婚呢？你知道的，我们可以结盟。弗蕾德贡德显然是冲着你来的。你是她儿子的对手。她会想除掉你的。这是一个一怒之下就会使用毒药的人。如果我们结婚，我就可以回到奥斯特拉西亚，为我的儿子担任摄政王。你可以摆脱弗蕾德贡德，确立自己为希尔佩里克的继承人，然后我们就可以联合两个王国，实际上作为国王和王后统治。”所以让我们理清头绪，汤姆。这个人是梅罗维克，他是希尔佩里克的儿子。
include Tours. But Merovitch has directly disobeyed these orders and instead has gone to Ruor. And he claims that it's to see his mother out of Ere, but it's clear that his real object is Brunhilde. And it's pretty clear that Brunhilde has written to him and said, look, why don't we get married? You know, we can have an alliance. Fredegund is clearly out to get you. You are a rival to her sons. She's going to want you out of the way. This is a person who is ready to practice poison at the drop of a hat. If we get married, I can go back to Australia and serve as regent for my son. You can get rid of Fredegund, establish yourself as Chilperik's heir, and then we can join the two kingdoms and rule effectively as king and queen. So let's just get our heads around this, Tom. So this guy is Merovec, and he is the son
还有阿尔德维拉。还有阿尔德维拉，她在修道院里。我们可以忘掉阿尔德维拉，她在修道院里。他是一个较大的儿子，他不喜欢新王后弗蕾德贡德并害怕她。嗯，我觉得更确切地说，弗蕾德贡德不喜欢他，因为弗蕾德贡德的权力取决于她自己的儿子成为国王，而不是他。所以他现在提议娶他叔叔的前妻，而这位前妻也是他父亲前妻的妹妹。
of Chilperic. And Aodivera. And Aodivera, who's in the convent. We can forget about Aodivera, she's in the convent. He's an older son, and he doesn't like Fredegund, the new queen, and fears her. Well, I think more to the point, Fredegundund doesn't like him because Fredegund's power depends on her son becoming king rather than him. So he's now proposing to marry his uncle's ex-wife who is also the sister of his father's ex-wife.
被谋杀的继母。对。好的。所以这真的很像一本奇幻小说。是的，非常清楚。被谋杀的。他父亲的前妻的，对。好的。所以这真的很像一本奇幻小说。是的，非常清楚。真的非常清楚。如果你理不清头绪，别担心，因为我也理不清。嗯，我认为其中的关键点在于，你说得对，这在技术上是乱伦。
Stepmother who's been murdered. Right. Okay. So it is very like a fantasy novel. Yeah, it's very clear. who's been murdered. Of his father's ex-wife, right. Okay. So it is very like a fantasy novel. Yeah, it's very clear. It's really clear. If you can't get your head around it, don't worry, because neither can I. Well, I think the key point there is that you're right that this is technically incest.
对。你会认为，例如，圣洁的主教们不会热衷于为乱伦盖章。但幸运的是，鲁昂的主教——你知道，一个享有很高声誉、非常尊贵的高卢-罗马贵族，名叫普里特萨图斯（Pritexartus）——他想，好吧，挺合理的，我来办。他之所以这么做，很可能是因为他是梅罗维克的教父。所以他某种程度上觉得自己有义务维持这种关系。于是他继续主持了仪式。布伦希尔德从她被囚禁的修道院里被解救出来。她结婚了，她自由了。
Right. And you would think that, for instance, holy bishops would not be keen to give their stamp to incest. But fortunately, the bishop of Rouen, who is, you know, a man of very holy reputation, very venerable Gallo-Roman aristocrat called Pritexartus, he thinks, okay, fair enough, I'll do it. And probably the reason that he does that is that he is the godfather of Merovich. And so he kind of feels obliged by that relationship. And so he goes ahead with the ceremony. Brünnhilde is sprung from this convent in which she's been imprisoned. She gets married and she is loose.
但还有一个转折，对吧？总会有转折。所以你以为梅罗维奇现在一切顺遂，但实际上，并没有。不。希尔佩里克对他来说太强大了。是这样吗？压倒了他并俘虏了他。俘虏了他，剃掉了他长长的头发，这当然是他皇室身份的象征。所以他基本上秃顶了，这是一场可怕的羞辱，然后把他送进了一座修道院，认为在那里他就不会再构成危害了。但梅罗维奇不吃这一套，所以他又把头发留长了，逃出了修道院，试图继续战斗，
But there's another twist, isn't there? There's always a twist. So you think Merovich has got it all going for him now, but actually, no. No. Chilperic is too strong for him. Is that right? Overpowers him and captures him. Captures him, shaves off his long hair, which of course is the mark of his royal status. So he basically goes bald and this is a terrible humiliation, and sends him off to a monastery on the assumption that there he will be no harm. But Merovich, he's not taking that, so he grows his hair back, he escapes the monastery, tries to continue the fight,
但他最终被逼到一个村子里，这个村子实际上离阿金库尔不远，也就是在法国的东北部。他知道现在，你知道的，他已经叛乱两次了。他不能期望从他父亲那里得到任何怜悯。于是他让他的仆人杀了他。而在奥斯特拉西亚，布伦希尔德在两年内第二次沦为寡妇。这很糟糕。但从积极的方面来看，她不再在修道院里了。她逃出来了。她回到了奥斯特拉西亚，她的儿子在那里是加冕国王。不仅如此，她还设法说服了勃艮第国王贡特拉姆（Gunthram）——也就是西吉贝尔特和希尔佩里克的哥哥——收养她的儿子希尔佩里克为王。我知道这里有数量极其庞大的疯狂名字。是的。但基本上布伦希尔德让她的儿子被勃艮第国王收养了，而
but he ends up cornered in a village that actually isn't far from Agincourt, so right up in the northeast of France. And he knows that now, you know, he's rebelled twice. He can expect no mercy from his father. And so he gets his servant to kill him. And back in Australia, Brunhilde is now being left a widow for the second time in two years. That's bad. But on the plus side, she's no longer in the convent. She's escaped that. She's back in Australia where her son is the crowned king. And not only that, but she's managed to persuade King Gunthram of Burgundy, so the elder brother of Sigurdbert and Chilperic, to adopt her son, Chilperic, as king. And I'm aware that there are an enormous quantity of mad names. Yeah. But basically Brunhilde has got her son adopted by the King of Burgundy and
弗蕾德贡德没有设法让她的儿子被收养。所以在这一点上她占了上风。对。事实上，随着布伦希尔德的好运轮盘上升，弗蕾德贡德的运气就开始下降了，你知道，你可能会想，为什么勃艮第国王贡特拉姆会收养他的侄子为王呢？难道他没有自己的儿子吗？嗯，他确实有过，但在当时席卷高卢的无休止的痢疾流行中，他们死去了。在580年，又爆发了一场痢疾，夺去了弗蕾德贡德两个儿子的生命。
Fredegund has not managed to get her sons adopted. So she to that extent is one up. Right. And in fact, as Brunhilde's wheel of good fortune goes up, so Fredegund's starts to descend and you know, you may wonder, well, why would King Guntrum in Burgundy adopt his nephew as king? Hasn't he got sons of his own? Well, he did have, but they had died in one of these endless dysentery epidemics that is always sweeping gall at this time. And in 580, there is another dysentery epidemic and this claims the lives of Fredigan's two sons.
这对她来说是毁灭性的，在个人层面上是毁灭性的，而且也是毁灭性的，因为她现在失去了当她的丈夫死去时，她作为王太后本应拥有的保障。如果你相信都尔的格里戈里的记述，她似乎因悲伤或受挫的雄心而发狂了——我是说也许两者皆有。根据都尔的格里戈里的说法，弗蕾德贡德指控阿尔德维拉最后一个活着的儿子克洛维斯——也就是娶了布伦希尔德的梅罗维克的兄弟——密谋通过巫术与弗蕾德贡德自己的一名仆人勾结来杀死她的儿子。克洛维斯据称一直与这个女仆有染，女仆的母亲是个女巫，这一切都是一种非常黑暗的
And this is devastating for her, it's devastating on a personal level and it's devastating because she has now lost the guarantees that she as Queen Mother would have when and if her husband dies. And she, if you trust Gregory of T's accounts, she seems to have been crazed either by grief or by frustrated ambition. I mean maybe both and according to Gregory of Taw, Fredegund accuses out of error his last surviving son Clovis, so that's the brother of Merovich who had married Brunhilde, of having conspired with one of Fredegund's own servants to kill her sons by means of witchcraft. And Clovis supposedly been having an affair with this servant girl, her mother was a witch, it's all a kind of very dark
阴谋。于是弗蕾德贡德去找希尔佩里克，说：“看啊，你儿子密谋反对我们的两个男孩，他跟一个女巫勾结，这太可怕了，你知道的，你必须好好收拾他。”所以希尔佩里克显然——如果这个故事是真的，这衡量了他对弗蕾德贡德有多么痴迷。他下令剥夺了克洛维斯的武器。这是他自己的亲生儿子。剥夺了他所有的华服，用铁链锁起来，交给了弗蕾德贡德。然后弗蕾德贡德把他带到了一处私人庄园。他在那里被关起来，套上锁链，据说自残身亡了。不过，正如谢莉·普哈克所指出的那样，他双手被反绑独自关在牢房里时怎么能做到这一点，却从未得到过解释。所以很可能，你知道的，又是弗蕾德贡德下手了。弗蕾德贡德再次出手了。是的。于是她还将那个所谓的女巫和她的母亲折磨并处决了，她还下令谋杀了阿尔德维拉。
conspiracy. So Fredegund goes to Chilperic, says look your son he's plotted against our two boys, he's engaged with a witch, this is terrible, you know you've got to sort him out. So Chilperic is obviously, I mean, it's a measure of if this story is true of how obsessed he is by Fredegund. He has Clovis stripped of his weapons. This is his own son. Stripped of all his finery, chained up, turned over to Fredegund. Fredegund then has him removed to a private estate. He's locked up there, chained and supposedly stabs himself to death. Although, as Shelley Puhuk points out, how he managed to do this while alone in a cell with his hands bound behind his back was never explained. So it's likely that, again, you know, Fredegund has struck. Fredegund strikes again. Yes. And so she also has the purported witch and her mother tortured and executed and she also has Aldevarra murdered as well.
所以她现在既摧毁了她作为王后的情敌，也消灭了她的两个继子。从这个角度来看，她成功地清除了障碍。但显然这也是个问题。她需要给希尔佩里克生个儿子。我的意思是，一切都取决于这一点。对她来说不幸的是，在582年，她成功做到了这一点。所以第三个儿子出生了，他也死于痢疾。哦，不。太糟糕了。但她认为这不仅仅是一场普通的痢疾死亡，对吧？
So she has now destroyed both her rival as queen and her two step-sons. So to that extent she has managed to clear the decks. But obviously it's a problem. She needs to give Chilperic a son. I mean, everything depends on that. Unfortunately for her in 582, she manages to do that. So a third son and he dies of dysentery too. Oh no. Terrible. But she thinks this is not just a common death by dysentery, does it?
她认为又有人——毒药牵涉其中，有人一直在密谋，对吧？巫术。巫术。我想到了这个时候，她和她的丈夫希尔佩里克，他们不断生儿子，儿子们却不断死于痢疾。是的。他们认为这一定是因为巫术。我想到了这个时候，她和她的丈夫希尔佩里克，他们不断生儿子，儿子们却不断死于痢疾。他们认为这一定是因为巫术。于是弗蕾德贡德指控当地的一位显贵干了这事。他受到了残酷的酷刑。他们拿来小木片
She thinks somebody has, again, poison has been involved, that somebody has been plotting this, right? Witchcraft. Witchcraft. I think by this point, both her and Chilperic, her husband, they keep having sons, the sons keep dying of dysentery. Yeah. They think it must be witchcraft. I think by this point, both her and Chilperic, her husband, they keep having sons, the sons keep dying of dysentery. They think it must be witchcraft. And so Fredegans accuses a local dignitary of having done it. He's tortured horribly. They take little shards
钉进他的指甲底下，手指甲和脚趾甲里。这是我绝对会向任何威胁要当场对我做这种事的酷刑折磨者妥协的事情。所以真的很可怕。她还把可能曾是助产士的各色妇女抓了起来。她将其中一些人斩首，一些人在火刑柱上烧死，另一些人则用车裂处死。接着，作为对她的悲伤、绝望和愤怒的高潮式宣泄，她做了一件将在几个世纪中久久回响的事，都尔的格里戈里对此进行了描述。王后现在收集了她死去的儿子曾经拥有的任何东西，把它们统统烧掉了——
of wood and drive them beneath his nails, his fingernails and his toenails. And that's something that I would always give in to any torturer who threatens to do that to me on the spot. So really horrible. And she also, she rounds up various women who were probably midwives. And she has some of them beheaded, some of them burnt at the stake, others broken on the wheel. And then as a climactic demonstration of her grief and her despair and her anger. She does something that will reverberate down the centuries, and Jeffrey of Taw describes it. The Queen now collected together anything that had belonged to her dead son, and burnt
他所有的衣服，其中有些是丝绸的，有些是皮草的，还有他所有的其他财物，凡是她能找到的。据说所有这一切装了足足四辆大车。任何金银物件都在炉子里熔化了，没有留下任何完好的东西来提醒她自己曾为这个男孩悲痛过。多米尼克，我们讨论过弗蕾德贡德以及布伦希尔德如何融入了瓦格纳伟大歌剧中的布伦希尔德这一形象。
it, all his clothes, some of them silk, and others of fur, and all his other possessions, whatever she could find. It is said that all this filled four carts. Any object in gold or silver was melted down in a furnace, so that nothing whatsoever remained intact to remind her of how she had mourned for her boy. And Dominic, we talked about how Fredegund as well as Brunhilde feeds into the figure of Brunhilde in Wagner's great opera.
她在火葬堆上自焚了。我认为这显然是对这场巨大篝火晚会的某种扭曲的回忆，那场大火烧毁了所有能让弗蕾德贡德想起她儿子的一切，所以你知道，对她来说这是一个毁灭性的时刻。但她并没有在火葬堆上自焚。事实上，她又生了一个孩子，她又生了一个男孩。她之所以这么做，是因为她和希尔佩里克对巫术感到如此恐慌，以至于当她怀孕时，她将其秘而不宣；当她生下儿子时，她也将这个秘密保守了下来。这意味着当在584年9月，外出打猎了一天的希尔佩里克回到他的别墅时，他从马上下来，迎面走来一个匆忙跑上前将他刺死并杀害的仆人。没有人知道他有一个男性继承人。天哪。那这个男孩多大了？我们知道吗？
She immolates herself on a pyre. And I think that this is clearly kind of distorted echo of this great bonfire of everything that had reminded Fredegund of her son and so you know it's a devastating moment for her. But she doesn't burn herself on the pyre. In fact she has another child, she has another boy. She does so because she and Chilprick are so nervous of witchcraft when she gets pregnant she keeps a secret and when she gives birth to her son she keeps that secret as well. So this means that when in September 584, Chilperic, who's been out for a day's hunting, returns home to his villa, he gets down from his horse and he is greeted by a servant who rushes up to him and stabs him to death. No one knows that he has a male heir. Crikey. So how old is this boy? Do we know?
所以这个男孩当时只有几个月大。天哪。现在，希尔佩里克被刺身亡了。现在，弗蕾德贡德陷入了绝境，是吗？还是说她实际上也插手了此事，汤姆？那可真是一个反转。汤姆，确实有人指控她谋杀了她自己的亲夫，因为每当发生神秘暗杀事件时，弗蕾德贡德总是会被指控。但如果你仔细想想，那将是疯狂的，因为对她来说，
So this boy is at this point a few months old. Crikey. So now, Chilprick has been stabbed to death. Now, Fredigan is up against it, is she? Or did she actually have a hand in it, Tom? That would be a twist. Tom Well, there are people who accuse her of having murdered her own husband, because whenever a mysterious assassination happens, Fredigan always gets accused of it. But if you think about it, that would be mad, because for her,
一切都取决于希尔佩里克的活着。她需要他，至少直到她生下的这个小男婴长大成人、能够继承乃父之位为止。失去希尔佩里克让她的命运命悬一线。所以如果你必须说，谁是最有可能的负责人的话，你可能会说是布伦希尔德，这并不是说布伦希尔德干的，但我的意思是，她必须头号嫌疑人，因为她当然不知道希尔佩里克有这个男性继承人。因此她会认为，随着希尔佩里克的出局，没有人可以宣称拥有纽斯特利亚王位，所以想必她现在正在密谋接管纽斯特利亚。
everything depends on Chilperic staying alive. She needs him, at least until this baby boy that she's got has grown up and come of age, able to succeed his father. The loss of Chilperic leaves her fortunes hanging by a thread. So if you had to say, well, who's the likeliest person responsible, you would probably say Brunhilde, which isn't to say that Brunhilde did it, but I mean, she must be the chief suspect because she of course doesn't know that Chilperic has this male heir. And so she would assume that with Chilperic out of the way there isn't anyone to claim the Noistrian throne and so presumably she is now kind of plotting to take over Noistria.
但弗蕾德贡德还有最后一张牌可打，于是她写信给勃艮第国王贡特拉姆。她透露了一个重磅炸弹般的消息：她有一个小男婴。她说：“愿我的主前来掌管他兄弟的王国。我有一个渴望放在他怀里的小婴儿。与此同时，我愿宣布自己是他卑微的仆人。”所以她把贡特拉姆的心思琢磨得透透的。她表现得顺从。她表现得谦卑。她说，你知道的，你可以统治纽斯特利亚。你可以照顾这个作为你侄子的男孩。贡特拉姆呢，被这番话迷住了。布伦希尔德不敢违背贡特拉姆的意愿。因此她不得不保持低调。于是弗蕾德贡德得以苟延残喘，再战江湖。所以弗蕾德贡德
But Fredegund has one last card to play so she writes to Guntrum, the King of Burgundy. She reveals the bombshell news that she has this baby boy. And she says, let my Lord come and take charge of his brother's kingdom. I have a tiny baby whom I long to place in his arms. At the same time, I shall declare myself his humble servant. So she's reading Guntrum like a book. She's being submissive. She's being subservient. She's saying, you know, you can have the rule of Neustria. You can look after this boy who is your nephew. And Guntrum is, you know, is charmed by this. And Brunnhilde doesn't dare go against Guntrum's wishes. And so she has to play quiet. And so Fredegund lives to fight another day. And so Fredegund has
打出了一记精彩绝伦的组合拳。她从危险的边缘为自己谋得了安全，多米尼克。在接下来的八年里，直到592年贡特拉姆去世，弗蕾德贡德和她的儿子——她给他起名叫克洛泰尔（Clothar）——基本上免受了布伦希尔德的复仇。在那段时间里，弗蕾德贡德基本上作为她儿子的摄政王统治着纽斯特利亚。你知道的，对于一个曾为奴隶的女性来说，能做到这一点是极其了不起的。我认为，这衡量了她在纽斯特利亚贵族中受到何等的尊敬和畏惧，他们才允许她这么做。与此同时，布伦希尔德被贡特拉姆死死勒住。
played a blinder. She's plucked security from the jaws of danger, Dominic. And for the next eight years, until Guntrum dies in 692, Fredegund and her son, who she calls Clothar, essentially are secure from Brunhilde's vengeance. And in that time, Fredegund essentially rules Neustria as her son's regent. You know, this is remarkable for a former slave to be doing this. And it's a measure, I think, of how respected and feared she is by the Neustrian nobility that they allow her to do that. Simultaneously, Brunhilde is kept on a tight leash by Guntrum.
她与他在一个叫翁德洛（Ondelot）的地方签署了一项条约。这是现存最古老的中世纪条约。我们依然保留着它。它签署于587年11月28日，这是现存最古老的中世纪条约，我们依然保留着它，它签署于587年11月28日，这是现存最古老的中世纪条约。这证实了布伦希尔德的儿子希尔德贝特将在贡特拉姆死后继承勃艮第。所以这对布伦希尔德来说是一次胜利。因此两人都得到了她们想要的东西：当贡特拉姆死时，布伦希尔德扩大了她儿子的领土；而只要贡特拉姆活着，弗蕾德贡德就免受布伦希尔德的复仇。
She has signed a treaty with him at a place called Ondelot. And this is the oldest surviving medieval treaty. We still have it. And it's signed on the 28th of November, 587, the oldest surviving medieval treaty, we still have it and it's signed on the 28th of November 587, the oldest surviving medieval treaty. And this confirms that Childerbert, who is Brunnhilde's son, will inherit Burgundy on Guntherm's death. So that's one up for Brunnhilde. So both of them have what they want. Brunnhilde has expanded her son's territories when Guntherm dies and Fredegund is secure from Brunhilde's revenge while Guntherum is alive.
嗯，我的意思是，总有一天贡特拉姆会死，然后宿怨大概就会重新开始。对。所以弗蕾德贡德一直在暗中对布伦希尔德实施一种普京式的肮脏战争。她煽动了一场针对布伦希尔德的叛乱，而布伦希尔德则亲自——你知道的——身披铠甲出征去平息叛乱。在586年，这就是
Well, I mean, one day Guntherum will die, and then the feud will restart, presumably. Right. So Fredegund, all the while, is kind of practicing a kind of Putin-style dirty war in the background against Brunhilde. She incites a revolt against Brunhilde, which Brunhilde personally, you know, she marches out in armour to put down. In 586, this is
主教普里特克·斯塔图斯在大教堂被谋杀的时候。这就是那个把布伦希尔德嫁给梅罗维奇的人。这就是我们在一开始提到的那个主教，据说当主教死去、鲜血洒满大教堂时，弗蕾德贡德在一旁幸灾乐祸。但与此同时，她自己却极其擅长维持公正。正如她从阴影中降下死亡一样，她也从阴影中施予正义。关于这一点有一个非同寻常的故事：某个家族内部爆发了世仇，他们都在互相残杀，于是她邀请了这个家族的三位主要成员——这场血亲复仇中各个派系的头目——参加了一场盛大的宴会，这三个在家族中结怨的成员被安排坐在她的大厅里。他们必须交出武器，在宴会期间必须彼此保持礼貌。
when Bishop Prytek Startus is murdered in the cathedral. So that was the one who'd married Brunhilde to Merovich. And this is the one we said at the beginning where Fredegant supposedly gloats over the bishop as he dies and the blood spills across his cathedral. But at the same time, she is brilliant at keeping justice herself. So just as she deals death from the shadows, so she deals justice from the shadows. And there's one extraordinary story that is told about this, that there's a vendetta has broken out in a particular family and they're all kind of killing each other and so she invites three of the leading members of this family, the kind of heads of the various factions in this blood feud to a great banquet and the three feuding members of this family are sat down in her great hall. They have to hand over their weapons, they have to be
端上了大量的食物，提供了大量的饮料。坚冰开始融化。到了傍晚结束时，这三个人都在聊天，仿佛他们已经冰释前嫌了。然后，一直在主宾席上观察这一幕的弗蕾德贡德给出了一个信号。三个男人，每人手里拿着一把斧头，走向这三个结怨的成员，随着“刷、刷”的声音，他们的脑袋在桌子上飞来弹去。弗蕾德贡德站起身来，走出了
polite to each other for the length of the banquet. Lots of food is served, lots of drink. The ice starts to melt. By the end of the evening the three men are all kind of chatting away as though they've kind of buried the hatchet. And then Fredegund, who's been watching this from the high table, gives a signal. Three men, each one man holding an axe, comes up to the three feuding members, swish with swish, their heads are sent bouncing across the table. Fredagund stands up, walks
房间，大厅里的每个人都知道她字面意义上执行了正义。威廉·巴伦：所以我觉得，你可以看出为什么她在纽斯特利亚人中既受尊敬又令人畏惧。但与此同时，这当然对她对抗布伦希尔德毫无帮助，因为她知道当贡特拉姆死后，布伦希尔德将发动进攻。对，于是我们来到了592年，贡特拉姆去世了，现在宿怨可以真正重新开始了。弗蕾德贡德知道布伦希尔德快要进攻了，对吧？绝对的，这发生在贡特拉姆死后的第二年。布伦希尔德命令她的军队攻占苏瓦松（Soissons），那是纽斯特利亚权力的主要中心。国库和其他一切都在那里。这对于弗蕾德贡德来说非常糟糕，因为布伦希尔德现在拥有
out of the room and everyone in her hall knows that she has literally executed justice. Will Barron So this I think is, you can see why she's respected and feared by people in Neustria. But all the while of course this isn't helping her against Brunhilde because she knows when Gunthram dies that Brunhilde is going to come on the attack. Right and so we get to 592, Gunthram dies and now the feud can restart in earnest. Fredericon knows that Brunhilde is about to attack right? Absolutely and this happens the year after Gunthram's death. Brunhilde orders her forces to capture Soissons, which is the main centre of Neustrian power. It's where the treasury is and everything. And this is very bad for Fredegund because Brunhilde now has the forces
勃艮第和奥斯特拉西亚的军队作为后盾。其数量远远超过弗蕾德贡德所能召集的任何人马。于是弗蕾德贡德一直在研究罗马军事手册，她在里面读到，处于劣势的军队想要击败规模更大的军队的唯一方法就是发动奇袭。因此她决定照此办理，试图在奥斯特拉西亚军队进攻苏瓦松之前对其进行伏击。于是她亲自率领她那处于绝对劣势的军队——她是战时领袖——从苏瓦松出发，她发现奥斯特拉西亚军队在一个叫布瓦西（Boisi）的村庄露营，弗蕾德贡德命令她的部队将铃铛系在马匹的缰绳上，
of Burgundy as well as Australia at her back. So massively outnumbering anything that Fredegund could summon. And so Fredegund has been studying Roman military manuals and she has read there that the only way that an outnumbered force can hope to defeat a larger one is to take it by surprise. And so she decides to do exactly that to try and ambush the Australian forces before they can attack Soissons. So she leads her hugely outnumbered forces in person she is the war leader out from so and she finds that the Australian forces are camped out at a village called Boisi and Fredegund orders her troops to fasten bells to the bridles of their horses So that the Australians will think that they are their own horses who are out grazing because that's what you would do. You would have your horses belled so that
这样奥斯特拉西亚人就会以为那是他们自己在外吃草的马匹。因为你通常会这么做。你会给马系上铃铛，这样它们就不会到处乱跑。所以当他们听到纽斯特利亚骑兵逼近时，他们会认为那只是我们自己的马在吃草。她做的另一件事，是命令他们携带树枝来伪装自己。这当然非常非常像比尔南森林。是的，非常像《麦克白》。有理论认为这正是《麦克白》中故事的最终来源，这是一个极其成功的策略。奥斯特拉西亚人完全被打了个措手不及，他们遭到屠杀，弗蕾德贡德
they won't wander off. So when they hear the Noistrian horsemen approaching, they think that's just our own horses kind of grazing. And the other thing that she does, she orders them to disguise themselves by carrying tree branches. And this is of course, very, very Burnham Wood. Yeah, very Macbeth. And there are theories that this is ultimately where the story in Macbeth comes from and it's a brilliantly successful strategy. The Austrasians are taken completely by surprise, they're put to the sword, massacred, Fredegun
随后率领突袭深入敌人领土，带着绝对满载的战利品凯旋苏瓦松。这是这两位竞争对手、弗蕾德贡德与布伦希尔德之间的最后一次重大对抗。她们做敌人太久了，以至于到了生命快结束时，她们本质上已经成为了彼此的镜像。在595年3月国王希尔德贝特——也就是布伦希尔德的儿子，既是勃艮第国王也是奥斯特拉西亚国王——年仅25岁便死于痢疾时，这一点变得更加清晰。所以又一次，他留下了两个儿子，听众们一定会很高兴地知道他们也有疯狂的名字。
then leads a raid deep into enemy territory and she returns to Soissons in triumph absolutely loaded down with booty. And this is the last great confrontation between the two rivals, between Fredegund and Brunhilde. And they've been enemies for so long that essentially by the end of their life, they have become the mirror image of the other. So this becomes even clearer in March 595 when King Childebert, so Brunhilde's son, King of Burgundy as well as of Australia, he's aged 25, he dies of dysentery. So yet again, and he leaves behind two sons and listeners will be thrilled to know that they also have mad names.
他们分别叫特乌德贝尔特（Theuderbert）和特乌德里克（Theuderic），非常年轻，而布伦希尔德现在作为摄政王代表他们统治。因此，弗蕾德贡德和布伦希尔德现在都是摄政王了，谢莉·普哈克在她的书《黑暗女王》中指出这是多么非凡。所以她写道：当布伦希尔德为她的两个孙子摄政时，她开启了欧洲历史上最不同寻常的时期之一，一个双雌统治的时期。她和弗蕾德贡德在完全相同的时间担任摄政王，她们共享的帝国涵盖了现代的法国、比利时、荷兰、卢森堡、德国西部和南部以及瑞士的部分地区。
So they are called Theuderbert and Theuderic, very young, and Brunhilde now rules on their behalf as regents. And so both Fredegund and Brunhilde are now regents and Shelley Buhaque in her book, The Dark Queens, points out how extraordinary this is. So she writes, when Brunhilde assumed the regency for her two grandsons, she ushered in one of the most unusual periods of European history, one of dual female rule. She and Fredegund reigned as regents at exactly the same time and the empire they shared encompassed modern-day France, Belgium, the Netherlands, Luxembourg, western and southern Germany and parts of Switzerland.
只有查理曼大帝才会短暂地控制比这两位女性更多的领土。太惊人了。我的意思是，令人惊异的是她们其实并不更为人所知。最了不起的事情是她们从未谋面。所以她们是势不两立的死敌，但她们从未谋面。弗蕾德贡德死于597年。在她的床上。安详地死在床上。
Only Charlemagne would briefly control more territory than these two women. Amazing. I mean amazing they're not better known really. The remarkable thing is they never met. So they're implacable enemies but they never met. Fredigan died in 597. In her bed. Safely in her bed.
是的。她的儿子克洛泰尔当时13岁，但他继承了与布伦希尔德的宿怨，他没有忘记，不是吗？是的，他确实没忘，而且你知道的，他还很年轻。他韬光养晦。所以在他的整个青少年时期到二十多岁期间都是如此。与此同时，在奥斯特拉西亚，布伦希尔德的两个孙子苏德贝尔特和特乌德里克反目成仇了。
Yeah. Her son Clothar was 13 but he's inherited the feud with Brunhilde and he doesn't forget it does he? Yeah he does and you know he's still pretty young. He bides his time. So all the way through his teenage years into his twenties. And meanwhile, in Austrasia, Brunhilde's two grandsons, Sudebert and Theuderic have fallen out with each other.
特乌德里克，那个较小的儿子，谋杀了他的哥哥。他当然会这么做。然后他从一口井里喝了水，结果得了痢疾。他死了。所以他出局了。他留下了三个儿子和一个女儿。他们都未成年。因此布伦希尔德现在不得不挺身而出，再次成为摄政王。而此时，她已经70岁了。基本上她的贵族们，奥斯特拉西亚的贵族们——我的意思是，
Theuderic, the younger son, murders his elder brother. Of course he does. He then has a drink from a well and he gets dysentery. He dies. So he's out of the way. He leaves behind three sons and a daughter. They're all underage. And so Brunhilde now has to kind of step forward and become regent again. And by this point, she is 70. And essentially her nobles, the nobles in Australia, I mean,
他们看到这个情景，说一个70岁的老太婆和一个幼年国王，这太无望了。你知道的，我们不能这样。于是他们转向了奥斯特拉西亚的弗蕾德贡德的儿子克洛泰尔，他们说，听着，这还不够好。采取这种接触的两个人是奥斯特拉西亚的两个主要人物。其中一个是名叫丕平（Pippin）的贵族。另一个是名叫阿努尔夫（Arnulf）的主教。他是梅茨的主教。这些都是法兰克人随后历史中的重要人物。他们说，听着，我们会抓住布伦希尔德和她的曾孙们，把他们保护起来并交给你。他们也确实这么做了。而且
they look at this and they say a 70 year old woman and, you know, an infant king, this is hopeless. You know, we can't have this. And so they turn to Clothar, Fredegund's son in Australia, and they say, look, this isn't good enough. And the two people who lead this approach are two of the leading figures in Australia. One of them is a nobleman called Pippin. And one of them is a bishop called Arnolf. He's the bishop of Metz. And these are significant figures in the subsequent history of the Franks. And they say, look, we will take Brunhilde and her great-grandchildren and we will secure them and we will hand them over to you. And that's what they do. And
布伦希尔德和她的曾孙们被用大车带到了克洛泰尔在奥斯特拉西亚北部建立的大营里。他们被带到他面前。两个大一点的男孩被斩首。女孩被发配到修道院。而最小的男孩，因为克洛泰尔是他的教父，所以免于一死，并被送走作为奥斯特拉西亚贵族长大成人。
they are Brunhilde and her great-grandchildren are taken in carts to the great camp that Clothar has set up in northern Australia. They're brought into his presence. The two eldest boys are beheaded. The girl is packed off to a convent. And the youngest boy, because Clothar is his godfather, is spared and is sent away to grow up
那克洛泰尔对布伦希尔德做了什么？布伦希尔德我想会期望她自己也会被送到修道院。她以前被捕时就是这样的。但克洛泰尔从他的母亲弗蕾德贡德那里继承了这场血亲复仇，他没有忘记。于是他以谋杀不少于10位国王的罪名对布伦希尔德进行审判，其中包括
as an Austrian nobleman. And what does Clothar do to Brunnhilde? Brunnhilde, I think, would be expecting that she too would be sent to a convent. That's what had happened before when she was captured. But Cothar has inherited this vendetta from Fredegund, his mother, and he has not forgotten it. And so he has Brunhilde reigned on charges of murdering no less than 10 kings, including
西吉贝尔特、梅罗维奇、克洛维斯、她自己的两个曾孙，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，很显然布伦希尔德并没有杀死其中任何一个人。本质上，这是一种粉饰弗蕾德贡德声誉的方式。布伦希尔德毫无意外地被判有罪，她的惩罚极其可怕。所以在奥斯特拉西亚和奥斯特拉西亚贵族这一排排森严的列队面前，她被公开剥夺了珠宝、长袍和所有华服。她随后遭到殴打、虐待。这持续了三天。她随后被反坐着骑在一头骆驼上游行穿过整支军队。当时她已经70岁了，提醒大家一下。
Sigurd Merovich Clovis, her own two great grandsons, which is mad. I mean, it's clear Brunhilde hadn't killed any of those. Essentially, it's a way of kind of whitewashing Fredegund's reputation. Brunhilde unsurprisingly is found guilty and her punishment is an absolutely terrible one. So in front of all this kind of serid ranks of the Austrasian and Austrasian nobility, she's publicly stripped of her jewellery, her robes, all her finery. She's then beaten, she's tortured. This goes on for three days. She's then paraded on a camel facing backwards and led through the entire army. She's 70 at this point, just to remind everybody.
她已经70岁了，却被当众骑着骆驼游街示众。这可不是她期望的晚年。然后，在她被骆驼游街示众之后，她被绑在一匹野马或几匹野马身上，或许是绑在它们的尾巴上，或许是绑在它们的蹄子上。野马的屁股上挨了鞭子，或许是蹄子上挨了鞭子，野马狂奔而去。布伦希尔德被绑在它们身上，很快就被折磨成了一堆血肉模糊的烂泥。据说她的脑袋飞了出去。她的四肢散落各处。克洛泰尔随后派出仆人去收集这些血淋淋的残骸，把它们带给他，
She's 70 and she's being paraded around on a camel. This isn't the old age that she was expecting. And then after she's been paraded around on the camel, she is bound to either a single wild horse or maybe several horses, perhaps to their tails, perhaps to their hooves. The wild horses, a lash is given to their rumps, perhaps to their hooves. The wild horses, you know, a lash is given to their rumps, they go galloping off. Brunhilde is tied to them and she is very rapidly reduced to a bloody pulp. Her head, it is said, is sent flying. Her limbs are scattered far and wide. Clothar then sends out servants to gather up the bloody remains they're brought to him,
然后举行仪式将它们焚烧，这样布伦希尔德就什么也不剩了。克洛泰尔在一旁看着，觉得自己终于战胜了他母亲的死敌；但在一旁观看的还有奥斯特拉西亚最伟大的两位贵族，正是他们的背叛将布伦希尔德和她的曾孙们判处了死刑，他们就是丕平和梅茨的主教阿努尔夫。他们共同的后代将会有一个非常非常光明的未来，一个如此光明的未来，以至于在适的时候它将掩盖墨洛温王朝的血脉。好吧，多么精彩的悬念啊。所以下周，法兰克人崛起的故事。
and they are ceremonially burnt so that nothing remains of Brunhilde, and Clothar watches feeling that he has at last triumphed over the great enemy of his mother, but also watching are those two greatest of Austracian noblemen, the lords whose treachery had doomed Brunhilde and her great-grandchildren, and they are Pepin and the Bishop of Metz, Arnulf, and their joint descendants, they will have a very, very bright future indeed, a future so bright that in due course it will come to blot out the very line of the Merovingians. Well, what a terrific cliffhanger. So next week, the story of the rise of the Franks,
它们被举行仪式焚烧，使得布伦希尔德不复存在，克洛塔尔看着，觉得他终于战胜了他母亲的伟大敌人，但同时也在观看的是两位最伟大的奥斯特拉西亚贵族，他们的背叛注定了布伦希尔德和她的曾孙们命运的领主们，他们是丕平与梅茨主教阿努尔夫，而他们共同的后代，将拥有非常非常光明的未来，这个未来如此光明，以至于在适的时候它将抹去墨洛温王朝的血脉。好吧，多么精彩的悬念。那么下周，法兰克人崛起的故事，
the Warlords of the West, takes an even more exciting turn as we come to one of the great decisive battles in medieval history or perhaps in all world history. The Battle of Tor. And if you want to hear that episode right away, you can of course do so by joining the Rest is History Club at therestishistory.com. And if you don't, I'm afraid you'll have to wait till Monday. And believe me, it will be worth the wait. All right. On that bombshell, thank you very much, Tom.
“西方军阀”迎来了更令人兴奋的转折，因为我们将迎来中世纪历史乃至世界历史上最具决定性的伟大战役之一——图尔战役。如果您想立即收听该集节目，当然可以通过访问 therestish.com 加入“历史就是一切”俱乐部来实现。如果您不想加入，恐怕只能等到周星期一了。相信我，等待绝对是值得的。好了，带着这个重磅消息，非常感谢你，汤姆。
Tor of Force, as always. Goodbye. ["Tour de force"] There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一如既往的杰作。再见。["杰作"] 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。